spee, ela
não fez
Li
mentir
foree
[Música]
discurso
sim, isso é czy Jerry Jerry oh, vamos lá,
podemos fazer isso
[Música]
lado [
Música]
w [
ela
[Música]
esse
idiota assiste
água
[Aplausos]
[  Música]
[Música]
antes que
eu
[Música]
não,
ei
[Aplausos]
[Música]
certo [
Música]
viva, nós [
Música] [
Música]
fizemos
eu
[Música]
Eu tenho que fazer alguma coisa, acho que todos nós
fazemos  como alguns, ele esqueceu seu
personagem [Música] e então vamos voltar
mais tarde, acho que vamos voltar para
o
grande Jo, ei, grande
[Música]
joe7 sim,
legal, posso tirar uma foto, sim,
sim, espere um segundo
antes de
falar
[  Música]
w
[Música]
meu então ele
oh
[Música]
w
depois que eu fiz
foi sim, cara, cara